what is up everybody its reverse coming
out here and welcome to another episode
of the week's best anime videos where
you can come to catch up on all the fun
stuff that you missed in the past week
links are in the description
recommendations go in the comments PS
team rowlett baby back on Thursday we
streamed the third episode of r & cafe
where we discuss the best and worst
anime characters and as always we had a
great time talking to each other and to
all of you guys in the chat thank you so
much for coming up r & cafe will be back
on this week on thursday at five PM
eastern standard time as usual and this
week we're going to feature another new
guest cyanide blizzard I actually saw
this guy in the red cafe shot a few
times but I didn't realize that he also
makes really funny and entertaining
content so I invited him to be our guest
and he agreed so that's gonna be a great
time be sure to come out and hang out
with us that's Thursday 5 p.m. eastern
standard time we're gonna be hanging out
with Mackel not bread from brands
fandoms and our new guest cyanide
blizzard so come hang out our general
topic for this week is going to be the
future of anime where is the industry
going where do we want it to go where do
we not want it to go and all that kind
of stuff as always that is just a
general guideline feel free to let us
know what you want to talk about in the
chat but speaking of the future of enemy
this week I came across a video in which
a bunch of modern animators who use AI
technology for their animations are
pitching their technology to hio
Miyazaki to legendary anime creator from
Studio Ghibli let's see what happened
there kudos wish to tell you tell me to
resume want internet I didn't want
manager please whole gamut of you guys
women management you are my attending
atrevida g'day o clock rejuvenate a
shuttle spiders and then one thing
committed monica same n typhoon which
okahandja
[Applause]
wow did you see that I think that was
the biggest burn I've ever seen in my
life like did you see those guys faces
oh man so yeah that's what we're going
to be talking about in Rand cafe this
week the future of anime is Miyazaki
right does he have a point here or was
the out of line we're going to talk
about all that kind of stuff so come
join us and speaking of our newest
ranked afaik s cyanide blizzard this
week he actually uploaded a video called
drifters first impressions in these
first impressions videos that he does he
starts off by making some really funny
satirical observations about the anime
he's reviewing along with some of his
friends and then he goes into a more
serious verdict about whether you should
watch the anime or not I really liked
the format of these videos I think
they're hilarious very entertaining so
definitely check out his channel after
for never rule talked about it last week
the anime man also made a video this
week talking about how underpaid manga
creators really are according to gintama
author hideaki sorracchi when a manga is
adapted into an anime series or a
live-action film the actual mangaka or
the manga creator only receives an
upfront one-time licensing fee which
means that no matter how popular the
anime or the movie ends up being they
receive the same amount of money it
doesn't matter the adaptation earns 1
million dollars or a hundred million
dollars the actual creator of the manga
still receives the exact same amount of
money that they received up front no
more and that's a writer myself this
seems really unfair to me because
without these writers there would be no
story there would be no anime there
would be no movie so it's really sad to
see how underpaid and underappreciated
they are by the industry the anime man
makes a really good point in this video
if you really want to support your
favorite author you have to buy the
original material as well you have to
buy the actual manga just watching the
anime buying the anime watching the
movie buying tickets to watch the movie
doesn't actually help the original
creator because he already received his
one-time fee and he's not gonna get any
more from that so if you really want to
support your favorite authors by the
manga aki dearest made a video this week
about the youtube glitch that a lot of
youtubers have been talking about lately
if you're a youtuber yourself and you've
been noticing some things being off with
your channel 2 views jumping up and down
or being lower than usual definitely
check out this video because aki makes
some really good points about what's
really going on
with YouTube at first I didn't pay much
attention to this YouTube glitch stuff
but lately I really have notice that
there's something going on if you look
at our latest rant cafe video the views
have been jumping up and down in the
last few days like crazy it went from
like 200-250 62 220 to 180 to 200 to 180
again so there clearly is something
going on with YouTube they don't really
want to admit it but something is
happening now we're a small channel over
here so our livelihood doesn't depend on
YouTube but I really feel for guys like
the anime man and Aki and lost paws who
made YouTube their career so every
glitch that YouTube has really affect
their bottom line really affects their
lives in a very big way I really hope
they're gonna sort it out soon this week
glass reflection amounts the 5th edition
of his review week of Awesome which is
going to take place between December
twelfth and December 16 this year is
going to be reviewing Tokyo ghoul
durarara jojo's bizarre adventure and
two other mystery anime now his reviews
are always phenomenal so I definitely
recommend checking out his channel now
do you ever find yourself being way too
excited way too soon for an anime
convention last Sunday our good friend
Mackel not made a skit about being a
little bit too excited for anime north
six months before it starts I am
actually featured in this kit so if you
want to check it out I definitely
recommend it and my favorite AMV of this
week was a mob cycle 100 and we called
awake by black beats FX this amv is high
energy high adrenaline and just overall
a kick-ass experience definitely check
it out so that's it for this week guys
if you enjoyed these videos be sure to
LIKE and subscribe and make sure that
you give me your recommendations for the
year's best anime videos which will be
coming out at the end of the year and
until next time see you space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]